[Music]
curiosity a blessing or a curse the
paradoxical nature of this trait was
personified for the ancient Greeks and
the mythical figure of Pandora according
to legend she was the first mortal woman
whose blazing curiosity set a chain of
earth-shattering events in motion
Pandora was breathed into being by
Hephaestus god of fire who enlisted the
help of his divine companions to make
her extraordinary from Aphrodite she
received the capacity for deep emotion
from Hermes she gained mastery over
language Athena gave the gift of fine
craftsmanship and attention to detail
and Hermes gave her her name finally
Zeus bestowed two gifts on Pandora the
first was the trait of curiosity which
settled in her spirit and sent her
eagerly out into the world
the second was a heavy box ornately
curved heavy to hold and screwed tightly
shut but the contents Zeus told her were
not for mortal eyes she was not to open
the box under any circumstance on earth
Pandora met and fell in love with
Epimetheus a talented Titan who had been
given the task of designing the natural
world by Zeus he had worked alongside
his brother Prometheus who created the
first humans but was eternally punished
for giving them fire Epimetheus missed
his brother desperately but in pandora
he found another fiery hearted soul for
companionship
Pandora brimmed with excitement at life
on earth
she was also easily distracted and could
be impatient given her thirst for
knowledge and desire to question her
surroundings often her mind wandered to
the contents of the sealed box
what treasure was so great it could
never be seen by human eyes and why was
it in her care her fingers itched to pry
it open sometimes she was convinced she
heard voices whispering and the contents
rattling around inside as if straining
to be free its enigma became maddening
over time
Pandora became more and more obsessed
with the box it seemed there was a force
beyond her control that drew her to the
contents which echoed her name louder
and loud
one day she could bear it no longer
stealing away from Epimetheus she stared
at the mystifying box she'd take one
glance inside then be able to rid her
mind of it forever but at the first
crack of the lid the Box burst open
monstrous creatures and horrendous
sounds rushed out in cloud of smoke and
swirled around her
screeching and cackling filled with
terror Pandora clawed desperately at the
air to direct them back into their
prison but the creatures surged out in a
gruesome cloud she felt a wave of
foreboding as they billowed away Zeus
had used the box as a vessel for all the
forces of evil and suffering he'd
created and once released they were
uncontainable as she wept Pandora became
aware of a sound echoing from within the
box this was not the eerie whispering of
demons but a light tinkling that seemed
to ease her anguish when she once again
lifted the lid and peered in a warm beam
of light rose out and fluttered away as
she watched it flickering in the wake of
the evil she'd unleashed
Pandora's pain was eased she that
opening the box was irreversible but
alongside the strife she'd set hope
forth to temper its effects today
Pandora's box suggests the extreme
consequences of tampering with the
unknown but Pandora's burning curiosity
also suggests the duality that lies at
the heart of human inquiry are we bound
to investigate everything we don't know
to mine the earth for more or are there
some mysteries that are better left
unsolved at Ted we believe in the power
of storytelling and that even the
youngest among us have ideas that should
be unleashed into the world if you're
curious about how to turn your
experiences dreams fears or hopes into a
TED style talk we want to help visit
Edie ted.com slash student talks to
unlock the next step